[music]
>> Point number three, this is our training
program will not provide you with all
the information, all the knowledge
required for Dawah.
Point number four,
it is not a knowledge based program,
but rather a technique based training
program.
I'll repeat, it's not a knowledge based
training program,
but it is rather a technique based
training program. So, even those people
who already full-time dies and may be
having sufficient knowledge would yet
benefit because it is a technique based
program. We have had training programs
only for graduates of University of
Medina.
All of them bachelors, some of them
masters, some of them PhDs.
But at the end of the program,
they are multiple times more beneficial.
They are multiple times more effective
as compared to what they were
though they spent about 7 years, 8
years, 10 years, 15 years.
The previous training programs I
conducted, there were even PhDs
from Medina University who did the
training.
They had the knowledge,
but after the training, they were
multiple times more effective in
conveying the message of Islam.
Point number five, however,
the basic bare minimum knowledge
and understanding of Islam
and other religions that is required
during the initial stages of Dawah will
be provided during the course of the
training.
The bare minimum. That means once you do
the course,
the knowledge given here
would be the bare minimum.
With that also you can do Dawah,
but to excel,
you will have to
gain more knowledge.
But the basics
will be taught inshallah. Point number
six,
sources of material for further
knowledge will be provided.
Point number seven,
special emphasis will be given
to the following,
techniques of public speaking,
structure and content
of Islamic talks,
techniques of handling the question and
answer session,
and debating skills.
Emphasis would be paid
on these particular points.
Point number eight,
we expect
all participants to become Islamic
orators
and give public talks on Islam and
comparative religion at a local,
national or international level.
We expect that each and every
participant
after he finishes the training program,
he would give Islamic talks at a local
level,
national or international level. And if
they're already involved in giving
lectures at a local, national or
international level, inshallah, we
expect them to be multiple times better.
And I was observing
while you were giving your
introductions,
masha Allah, the selection made by
brother Kaleem from the several hundred
applications is alhamdulillah good.
I was actually judging
that did he do a good job or not.
So, I told him
before
I started, so far it is good,
alhamdulillah.
One thing is
that when you take an interview,
you come to know something which is
maybe shallow and something which is
in-depth. So, one judgment interview is
something which you can judge at a low
level, but later on you realize that was
superficial.
The depth
of that person you realize later on.
So, so far I told him alhamdulillah,
it's a very good choice, alhamdulillah.
Point number nine,
we expect participants to become future
trainers
for Dawah training programs, inshallah.
That besides you giving public lectures,
we also expect you to become future
trainers,
so that you could also produce or
inshallah train more dies. As far as
these first nine points are concerned,
does anyone have any query?
Any questions regarding the objectives?
The first nine points we covered in the
objectives,
does anyone have any questions regarding
these objectives?
Crystal clear?
Masha Allah.
Even there are no questions, it means
two things.
Either everyone understood everything
or didn't understand anything.
So, that we come to know later on.
Inshallah. Yes, brother, you have some
question.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. My question is, is there any
specific level of knowledge that we need
to gain for this particular program that
will make us effective dies?
If I understood your question correctly,
that do you have to have certain level
of knowledge to be effective dies?
The minimum,
as I said that Dawah is a great field
and no one can say that he has got all
the knowledge, but the bare minimum
required
for a person would be covered in this
course.
Bare minimum means if you have this
knowledge, yet masha Allah, you can
convey the message of Islam to many
people. And what are the basics will be
discussing.
So, that is the reason when I talk about
Christianity, I'll be talking about
basics. When I talk about Hinduism, I'll
be talking about basics. All this will
be covered during that session. So, what
basic is required? Inshallah. But to do
this course, one of the criteria that we
were checking when the applications
came, number one as was mentioned in the
form, is fluency in English.
Since this program is in English,
fluency is important. Though we did
compromise because we wanted different
nationalities and we wanted the training
program to be international, so we did
compromise on the English depending on
the nationality. But if we had
from the same nationality,
then but national person speaking better
English has more chances. Point number
two,
we also checked the passion the person
has
for doing Dawah.
And that was a very important factor,
though
this
judgment in interview
is subjective.
For example,
one of the participants got into it
because he said if you don't take me,
I'll get a heart attack.
I mean, I'm a doctor.
Not that I believed in it literally, but
I liked the passion, okay, fine. And
many a time, you know, many of the
courses that we have whether getting
admission to the school, I always check
the passion. And there never has been a
case even in admission to our school
that a person who was very passionate
and was consistent has not got
admission.
The person who's consistent
shows that he has the
passion and
the chances of it being correct is high,
but not always 100%.
Even the Iman keeps on going up and
down. Even the Sahabas,
the Iman kept on going up and down, but
the lowest level of Iman was also very
high, masha Allah. Though the Iman kept
on going up and down depending on the
situation of the Sahabas who are the
best examples after the Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
But the point to be noted that even the
lowest was on a very high level.
So, passion was one of the criteria that
we checked,
which is difficult to judge. And a
person who's passionate, even if he
knows he's not going to get, he prays to
Allah and he keeps on striving.
And we'll come to it later on what is
advantage of striving.
So, second is passion. Third is the
person having knowledge of Islam. If a
person is already
educated in the field of Islam, having a
bachelor's degree from a very well-known
Islamic institute or a master's degree
or a PhD,
that if he learns these things, the
chances of him being effective is more.
But if he has the degree, but is not
passionate,
then he would not qualify.
So, it was a combination of many things,
but in this course, inshallah,
irrespective whether you have the
knowledge or not, the bare minimum if
you do your homework properly, the bare
minimum required for you to be at least
a die on a smaller level
would be sufficient, inshallah. Hope
that answers the question.
Anyone have any other questions
as far as the first nine points are
concerned?
We move on to the 10th point.
Besides preparing for Islamic public
talks,
this training will inshallah enhance
the effectiveness of Dawah on an
individual level by giving you more
self-confidence and correct techniques.
That means though
this program
is targeted
at techniques of public speaking skills
on a high level, on a public level, it
will indirectly also benefit you in
one-to-one Dawah.
That does not mean because we are
targeting speaking at a public level,
while you're being trained for that,
indirectly, even your one-to-one Dawah
will become effective.
I mean,
people normally tell
that Zakir is specialized
for non-Muslims.
I do agree with them to a certain level,
but not completely. Yes, I am
specialized in Islam and comparative
religion. I'm specialized. He's
specially meant for non-Muslims. No. The
audience that I have, more are Muslims.
Peace TV is watched by 75% Muslims and
25% non-Muslims.
Though my specialty is speaking to
non-Muslims, I'm doing Islah
of the Muslims that they should do
Dawah.
So, the goal is non-Muslims, but I speak
to the Muslim what I'm doing now.
Am I speaking to non-Muslims now?
The audience here is 100% Muslim and
more committed Muslims.
So, though I'm specialized
in speaking to non-Muslims, I'm
addressing the Muslims to speak to the
non-Muslims.
For the people watching Peace TV more
are Muslims. 25% non-Muslims, 75%
Muslims. Though my target is non-Muslim
and comparative, what am I doing? I'm
getting the Muslims together on a common
platform. At the same time, training
them how to speak to the non-Muslims.
So, directly I may be speaking to less
of non-Muslims,
but finally it reaches the non-Muslims.
Alhamdulillah. So, saying I'm
specialized in non-Muslims is correct,
but though I speak to Muslims more.
The same with this training program,
while you're being trained
to speak on a public level,
your level of speaking individually
one-to-one will also enhance to a great
level, inshallah.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
[music]